so healthcare in the US anyway is
clearly more of a sick care system and
healthcare system leave wait until
people get quite ill and then we try to
hold them back and we need to change our
focus in towards prevention as somebody
who had the privilege of leading the
Human Genome Project I think we have
something to offer here because the
discovery of genetic variations that
play a role in disease risk is happening
all around us it's a deluge of
information that should provide the
opportunity to give people the chance to
practice prevention much more effective
because it can be done as an individual
activity instead of a generic one size
fits all so my hope would be that in
this health care reform that we're
getting into we will focus more on
prevention to try to reduce our health
care costs him on power people to have
information about themselves it's
actionable kumon that they can use in a
fashion that is not so generic but is
really specific for them to focus on
staying healthy and that might be by
knowing what your risks were in an
adjusting diet exercise medical
surveillance all of those things to do
what's right for you might not be right
for the next guy but it's right for you
and have a better chance of living a
long life without chronic illness or
premature terrible things like cancer or
heart disease or stroke and that's a big
picture texts if we invest ourselves in
the research and in the policy decisions
we ought to get